all right we're back on overtime we've
got filmmaker of the HBO documentary the
insurrectionist next story Alexandra
Pelosi we have New York Times colist
blett Stevens and we have CNN
contributor and Democratic strategist
Paul bagawa and these are the questions
hot off the
press I hold in my
hand one not had you just do carck and
with their mind okay uh should
Rashida T oh oh yes should Rashida Talib
who by the way uh still has not
acknowledged that the missile that
killed the hospital was not an Israeli
missile still telling the LIE uh before
should she be forced to take down the
Palestinian flag flying outside her
office yeah I I saw that picture oh
there you have it um no the answer is no
no we no I mean I I I I despise her
political views but absolutely not she's
an American she can do whatever she
wants
but okay I mean uh and and I mean this
is this is the American the American
Congress has this been done before do
other PE they like to I mean people come
from different countries do they then
fly the I mean there's plenty of people
I'm sure who have Heritage from Mexico
did they put the Mexican flag outside
their office it's it's I think voters
should make judgments about her
political choices but I think it's the
essence of a democracy so you can fly
the
flags you do you stand on this one I'm
not touching that you're not touching
you are afraid to getc but I will say
wait but here's the thing I will go into
I support the whole concept of free
speech right and one of the main things
I talk about in my movie is about when
does Free Speech become hate speech and
when do we go after people and call it
hate speech which was where the whole
thing about getting canceled comes from
like I'm afraid to talk about that
because I don't want to get canceled
that's people are going to say it's hate
speech well what okay why don't we just
call it yeah shitty speech yeah I I not
I'm not it's in the eye of the hate
speech is a concept that's always in the
eye of the beholder spech is speech that
I hate so don't don't don't say I
disagree right but there's this whole
thing called Free Speech but who cares
if nobody's listening we're not
listening to each other so who
cares I've never been in love with the
concept of looking into people's minds
when they commit crimes it's a crime you
need to pay for it if it if you
committed the crime why you did it I
don't know that that gets into crazy
kind of territory of thought crime CRI
right which is exactly where we don't
want to go but yeah I no I agree she she
can fly the flag anywhere but what is it
say about you know your just it just
seems like your loyalties are a little
too divided agree and let the voters of
Bishop draw their conclusions next year
I know how I would vote if I were in her
District but uh um absolutely I'm going
to stand up for her right to to what do
you think of Putin's meeting with X
that's right Putin of Russia and X of
China boy these two they like have
friendship bracelets one
says one says and the other says
America you know forming a new axis of
Evil Boy I mean I you go but it's weird
because China and Russia were always at
each other's throats and and and Putin
has this sort of Fanboy appeal to the
far right in the Republic of to a lot of
Republicans which I find astonishing
because they'll tell you they hate the
Chinese Communist party okay good I'm
with you buddy but they love Putin by
the way Putin was meeting with with shik
Nala the head of Hezbollah right he's he
is behind all of the worst things and
the worst people in the world and I
think this is something Biden deeply
gets which is that dictators by Nature
unite whatever their geopolitical
differences right they are birds of a
feather they see themselves as uh
authoritarians who want to destroy the
free world and that's why it's important
to have leaders in the Free World who
recognize what the threat they posed
Hamas Iran China Russia North Korea they
all have something in common what what
did Nazi Germany and Japan really have
in common except oh we're the bad
guys like that's right you're right
there was really I guess what the plan
did was there ever even a plan we're
going to divide up the world we're going
to conquer each our Hales and then we'll
then obviously they would have turned on
each other like Hitler turned on Stalin
it's weird uh do you think Mitt Romney
is right to blame Fox News and
right-wing media for radicalizing the
GOP boy when mint Romney becomes and he
you know I I must say mint Romney he's
said he is who he is this the kind of
guy you know like he's the he's he irons
his underwear and you know he just you
can't I mean I when he ran for president
I was unmerciful but he was just be you
know he's just being the person he was
born he he's just you know he's met
Romney but Alexander I'm sure you saw a
lot of people who were poisoned by Fox
News I I I keep referring to your
interview with Bill because the it's the
downstream effect the they're drinking
we say in Texas the water won't clear up
until you get the hogs out the creek
okay all these people are drinking all
this ship that rer moch and and and the
social media companies are putting in
the water right yes
more like that that's how you get
elected in this country you come out
with stuff like that but you saw them
you saw the victims of that poison right
absolutely it's really toxic and then of
course it goes even worse into the
political violence territory and I'll
tell you this he's making fun of me for
this but I'm saying I have to be careful
because I don't want a guy to break into
my house with a hammer and trying and
kill me night and I'll tell you
something I get you come look at my
inbox and you'd be you'd be in
your pants if you saw my
inbox how could these people want they
want to kill me because why I don't get
it I get that I don't get the cancel
part oh okay
remember about about um I get the kill
you're right about
that about mitt I think I think he's
proved himself to be a great American he
voted for impeachment twice anyone he
really did anyone who is willing to
stand up to the assholery of your own
side deserves a place in the American
Pat and and there's a few with it Liz ch
there's a few of them were there no
there was a bridge too far I I hear a
lot I really do from Republicans on the
hill about their personal safety one of
the reasons I don't want to break with
with the Cs is their personal security
Mitt Romney it's been reported spends
$5,000 a day on security for himself and
his family he's a very wealthy man but
most members are not wealthy and there
is an honest Fear Factor that is real
and legitimate that is causing a lot of
these Republicans to cower okay what
does the panel think of Gavin nome's
trip to Israel and China is he setting
himself up for a presidential run I mean
I it does kind of look like he's running
to be the standin in Casa I'm not saying
I'm wishing for something to happen to B
but is a little Prince Charles when the
mother was still alive feeling
to
no yeah and he went to the debate the
Republican debate he went to the last
Republican debate with Joe Biden's
blessing and carried the the torchure
for Biden and the Democrats I thought he
did a great job and you don't think he'd
be a better candidate than Biden not
better than Biden but but one day he
he'll probably run and that'll be great
okay all right thank you everybody we
appreciate your
patience we will see you next
[Applause]
week